rmx logic transcriptomics is an online  training program for students  researchers and clinicians it is  designed to introduce participants to  the various aspects of rna-seq data  analysis and application to basic  research biotechnology and biomedical  projects and see how rna-seq is used for  real-world biomedical applications in  this program we will see how relying on  analytical methods and reference  databases researchers can study rna-seq  data to understand gene expression  variation across many conditions to do  so effectively bioinformaticians  leverage big data processing methods  organized into bioinformatics pipelines  and perform exploratory data analysis  and normalization  apply statistical methods for rigorous  hypothesis testing and rely on data  mining and machine learning we will  combine online interactive sessions  self-guided study materials and  practical assignments for an immersive  experience